Fowler: Hope you've had
a fun time fiddling
with your new phones.
I'm Martin Fowler.
This is Rebecca Parsons.
We both--we'll be talking about
some of our experiences
and thoughts for the future
about Google's App Engine,
particularly
the new App Engine for Java,
which several
of our colleagues were able
to spend some time experimenting
with earlier this year
and get some preliminary
thoughts about.
To begin with, I think
we'll talk a little bit about
who ThoughtWorks is
just in case you don't know.
We are a company
that builds applications
for people, primarily.
We're about 1,000 or so people
scattered around the world.
And we do a variety
of different kinds
of applications.
Some are internalish style
I.T. applications,
such as one we worked on
for Caterpillar.
We do some very public
web-fronted applications
such as Guardian online,
which is a well-known
English language newspaper
and media source.
We build products
for other people.
So Insurecom example
is a case where we built
a product for a company
that then sold it
on to its customers
which are insurance brokers.
And we do some products
of our own kind.
So example of that is Mingle,
which is a project collaboration
and management tool.
We use a range of different
platforms and languages.
I would say
the vast majority of our work
is either Java or .net.
Probably slightly
majority .net at the moment.
But there's a significant
amount of Ruby that we do.
And we also do smatterings
of little environments as well.
We like to play with lots
of different things.
And our projects can be
for all about one or two people
up to a couple of hundred's
probably our biggest
at the moment.
So we have quite a range
of different kinds of projects
that we do.
And quite a range of stuff
that we work with.
For the first part
of the talk,
I'm going to primarily
lead off
and talk about some
of the experiments that we did
with Google App Engine.
We were in that kind of early,
see-it-before-it's-released
phase
and were able to get some people
to work with it.
And then Rebecca
is gonna concentrate
on talking about
some of our broader thoughts
about the cloud.
But we'll be interrupting
each other as we go.
Parsons: Of course.
Fowler: So we'll begin
with the experiments.
And essentially what we did
with the experiments
is we launched a bunch
of people out
to say
here's Google App Engine,
you've got a few days,
perhaps in between projects
or we managed to allocate
some time,
experiment with
some interesting stuff
and tell us your conclusions.
In fact, if you hunt around
on the ThoughtWorks blogs
you can find a lot
of this kind of information.
So a couple of people decided
they wanted to play around
with the Clojure programming
language
which is built on top
of Java.
Another guy, Ola Bini,
played around with JRuby.
Ola's one of the main committers
to JRuby,
so he's a perfect person
to do this.
And one of our folks
in India decided
to work a little bit
with the GWT and JDO
in a more straightforward
use of the Google App Engine.
And Paul Hammant
decided as usual
to do some really freaky stuff
involving Rich Clients.
His aim is to try
and get rid of Flash
and all this proprietary
Rich Client stuff
and instead have source
downloaded through...
in his case, using pieces
of either JavaScript
or his particular preference,
using Ruby
to execute
on the client's side.
So we had a bunch of different
interesting things
to work with.
I believe Paul is doing
something in the, um...
Parsons: Sandbox.
Fowler: Sandbox tomorrow.
So certainly
take a look at that.
So all of this stuff
really is based on the idea
that, well, we have a cloud
and we have on that cloud
Java.
But from perhaps what a couple
of those experiments
might've indicated,
it's actually not really Java
that's on the cloud.
It's much more the JVM itself.
And one of the consequences
of the fact
that you've got
the JVM on the cloud
is that
you've got this ability
to bring out
alternative languages.
And that was clearly,
as you see,
a part of some
of the experiments we do.
Clojure and JRuby--
But there's a lot of other,
of course, interesting languages
that have been built
on the JVM recently,
all of which are potentially
capable of running
on the Google App Engine
for Java.
Why is this interesting
to us?
Well, I mentioned earlier on
that we have got a significant
proportion of projects
that we've done in Ruby
over the last few years--
40-odd projects
that we've done in Ruby.
And one of the things
that I did recently
as the basis for a talk that
I gave at another conference
was ask the question
of the people
who worked on those projects
which was really
about productivity.
Is it more productive
to use Ruby
than a more mainstream Java
or C#-style stack?
And we're talking here
about Java
or C# used intelligently,
that is, not with
lots of EJBs or BizTalk
or other productivity
destroyers.
And the answer,
in a broad sense,
was what you see here.
The--in fact...
I can boil down this answer,
in fact, to this pie
which basically says
that a significant percentage
of the people felt
that they were at least
50% more productive working
in Ruby than they were in Java.
And that's a significant piece
of information.
And that's also a piece
of information
that leads into some of these
other languages as well.
But there are some important
productivity benefits
about using some
of these languages
that are built
on top of a JVM
but not
being Java themselves.
And that's why
we're interested in the fact
that it's the JVM
that's on the cloud
rather than just Java
on the cloud.
Now having said this,
let's be honest about this.
Most of the time,
people who are gonna be using
Google App Engine for Java
are gonna be using Java.
The vast majority
I would expect
would be cases of people
using Java.
But it's worth
bearing in mind
those other languages
simply because
of the potential productivity
gains they can provide.
Parsons: Particularly since
many of those languages
are designed for
a particular purpose.
And it's not so much
that Ruby is this great,
wonderful language
that's so powerful,
but if you lessen the distance
between what it is
you're trying to express
and the language
and what's natural to express
in that language,
you are going to get
productivity improvements.
So if you need a general purpose
language, great.
If you can get by
in a very specialized language
because you have
a very specialized problem,
then the fact that
we have the JVM here
on Google App Engine
means that we can use
those more specialized
languages.
Fowler: So the headline news
is Google App Engine
takes Java and the JVM
and puts it on the cloud.
However, the JVM isn't quite
all there as we know it.
Usually for good reasons
there are little holes
in the JVM
which means that if you
just want to take some app
that's been developed
on Java,
you can't just say,
"Oh, let's just put--
"copy the files
and transfer it
to the Google App Engine
for Java and it will just work."
It won't just work.
There are definitely
different ways you have to think
about developing
on the Google App Engine
than you would
on a more traditional
enterprise, Java-style stack.
And there are three areas
that experimenters
highlighted
as issue areas
of things where you
have to particularly
bear them in mind.
And I'm really gonna
go through these three areas
as really the main conclusions
from our experiments
starting with testing.
And testing is important
to me personally
and to most of us
at ThoughtWorks
because we are pretty anal
about testing.
Whenever we see ourselves
writing any code,
we always want to execute it
through tests.
It's become a major part
of our discipline
of development.
And we do it partly
because of the fact
that it allows us to put
systems in production
with way less bugs than
otherwise would be possible.
But primarily because it
actually makes us
more productive.
Although it may seem like
you're taking a lot of time
to spend a lot of effort
in testing efforts,
you make up that time hugely
by the fact
that you're not spending
so much time debugging.
And we think that this approach
to testing is very important.
And furthermore, it's a testing
that we do at multiple levels.
So you have JUnit style,
Java unit test kind of levels
that go on with
a fairly tight loop.
And then a longer loop
that uses more functional
or acceptance tests using tools
like Selenium
or Watir or WebDriver
it it's a web app
or other tools that we put
together for non-web apps.
But we have multiple layers
of testing
and these are automated tests.
So that as a result
we can take any version
of our system,
we can compile it,
automatically test it,
and get some sense
as to whether there's any bugs
lurking around there.
This is very much a core way
in which we work.
And so any testing issues
for the Google App Engine
are very important.
Now when it comes
to executing some code,
you've got two basic choices
in a Google App Engine
environment
for how you're going
to execute the code.
One is to execute it
on the remote App Engine itself
on the Google data center.
But also you have
the option of executing it
in a local development
environment.
It's a special development
server
that has been put together
for testing purposes.
Both of these environments
have strengths
and weaknesses in use.
The first thing about working
with the remote application
engine
is you have to remember
you're working with
a somewhat thinner pipe
than you're gonna have
with a local development
server.
And this is particularly
important to you
if you're running these
fine-grained unit tests
where you're typically wanting
to be able
to run a test where you can
get an answer back
in a matter of seconds.
The fact that you actually have
to get the code
and ship it all over
onto the Google system
to be able to do that,
that becomes
a significant factor
when you're wanting
that degree of turnaround time.
Then there's a couple
of other red flags
that you have to deal with
as well.
One is that in order
to actually execute stuff
on the Google App Engine,
it has to start up at JVM
whenever you want
to fire things off.
And that still is a significant
bit of lag time
that's involved.
And, again, in the course
of what you have to do
to get something on production,
it's not that big a deal.
But when you're trying to run
a rapid rate of unit tests,
then that startup time
can be a significant factor
in your timing.
The other problem with using
the Google App Engine
is it's very difficult
to actually do
the classic running
a set of unit tests.
There's no real facilities there
in order to be able to do
that run app at the moment.
It's fine if you're using some
kind of more web-driven approach
like Selenium or WebDriver
or the like.
But for just running a batch
of unit tests,
the App Engine
isn't really suited
for doing something like that
at the moment.
So a logical thing therefore
is to say well, we want
at least a significant part
of that testing
to be done through
the local development server.
But yes, we have some red flags
there as well.
And they really boil down
into two main problems.
The first one and I think
the most serious one
is that
the local development server
isn't really an accurate clone
of what's going on
on the Google App Engine
itself.
All of our experimenters
ran into little cases
where things wouldn't work
on the local development server
but would work
on the full Google setup.
And that, of course,
can lead to a lot of frustration
because then you're faced
with the problem
of, "Hmm, what do I do here?"
Do I code around the local
app server
even though it's going
to work fine remotely?
Or do I have to disable
certain tests
because they're going to fail
for effectively spurious
reasons?
And then of course
you get the reverse problem
where it's going to work
on the local system
but not work on the remote one.
And you don't have to run
into too many of those glitches
before you begin to lose trust
in the local development server.
The second area
where you run into difficulty
is in order to use Google
App Engine effectively,
you want to use
a lot of the services
that are packaged
in with the App Engine.
But, of course, they're not
gonna run on your local server.
So what Google does give you
is a certain degree of ability
to be able to stub
those Google services
so that you can at least
run test cases.
But stubbing isn't always
what you want.
And the way things are set up
makes it rather difficult
for you to actually put
your own stubs into place,
which a lot of the time
is what you'd want to do.
And that problem is one
that will also exacerbate
running the tests locally
on the local development server.
Parsons: Now the good news
about a lot of those things
is the fact that they're
all fixable problems.
We pushed on the App Engine
in a way
that traditional standard Java
applications probably wouldn't.
And as we run into those,
those problems can be fixed
to make sure
that the local clone
is more and more in align
with what the cloud is.
So as we run into those things,
they can be fixed.
So it's something that
we expect to continue to improve
as this product
gets more usage
and we have more opportunities
to be able
to push on this in particular
in the testing.
We know that we push things
in testing
far more than other people do,
and so we kind of expect things
like this.
Fowler: So there's
kind of two messages--
with all of these three points
there's kind of
two message streams here.
One is to Google.
And my message here to Google
is get that
local development server
so it's a proper clone.
Make it so that you can easily
replace those stubs.
That's stuff
that Google needs to do.
And for people who are thinking
of deploying
on the Google App Engine,
be wary about the testing.
It's gonna be more awkward
for a while
than we'd ideally
like it to be.
And probably
a lot of the testing
is ending up gonna have
to be driven
through the App Engine,
through the browser.
You're gonna rely on more
of that than you would like
when you prefer running
local unit tests.
There are things you can do
to make sure
as minimum amount of tests touch
the tricky areas as possible.
But you aren't going
to be able to build
as broad a unit test net
as you would like,
at least until the local
development server improves
its mirroring.
So that's our message
with testing.
So the second topic
to move into is persistence.
Now, as you may know,
Google provides a persistence
mechanism for you
called BigTable, which
is a very proven approach
to handling persistence
for this kind
of cloud architecture
because it's what Google uses
for, well, Google Search.
And we know that
that is battle proven
with lots and lots of usage.
And if you listen
to the descriptions,
and indeed the name BigTable,
you'll say to yourself,
"Oh, yes,
tabular data structures.
"This is the kind of thing
I'm familiar.
"Rows and tables.
"I have a row, a table.
Rows, and I
have columns there."
Except those columns
can be any--
given any arbitrary name
that's some string.
And not all rows of this--
no notion of rows
of a particular type
where the columns
are all expected to be there
because any row
can have any column it likes.
Hang on--this is not feeling
like a table particularly.
In fact, my view is thinking
of BigTable as a table
is just going to lead you
mentally down the wrong path.
Well, instead you have
to say to yourself is,
"What we have here
is a nested HashMap."
We basically have
some row pointer
that gives you
a bunch of--
basically points you to a
HashMap with a bunch of keys.
which itself gives you
various bits of data.
And a nested HashMap is a very
appropriate data structure
for this kind of setup.
I don't think it's
particularly coincidental
that you look at a number
of big web properties
and they've moved towards
a nested HashMap style
data structure
for what they do.
Amazon, for instance, also uses
a nested HashMap style model
with its S3.
But it is a different one
to what most enterprise
developers are familiar with
because in the enterprise,
relational databases
rule supreme.
Now there's a bit more
to the nested HashMap story.
We also have the ability
in BigTable
to effectively have
time-stamped versions
of data for each of the keys
that you have.
Now this is actually potentially
a very useful capability
to allow the database to act
in a much more temporal way
and be able to record
a history of information
as opposed to just purely
current snapshots.
But again, this is a relatively
unfamiliar thing
for most of the developers
that are used to developing
with relation to databases.
Now, that's
the underlying engine.
If you use BigTable,
you will access it
through various APIs.
And there are three main APIs
practicing from Java.
One is a data store API,
and the data store API
is the one that is really
the most natural one
to the underlying data
structure.
That is the one
that gives you the feel,
I'm talking to a nested
HashMap here.
Then there are two higher level
APIs, JDO and JPA,
which are fairly standard
Java or entered APIs.
You see them around a lot.
And what that can lead some
people into thinking perhaps
is that, well, if we
code our application based
on JDO or JPA,
we don't really have to care
about the fact
that it's BigTable
as opposed
to a relational database
sitting behind the scenes.
We can hide the fact that
we're dealing with BigTable.
Just write our application
to those higher level APIs,
and all will be fine.
You probably will hear people
claiming that.
Maybe even people have claimed
that at this conference.
I have a one-word response
to that claim.
Bollocks.
The thing with persistence
that we've learned
time and time again
is that these abstraction layers
are extremely valuable,
they save you an enormous
amount of effort,
but they only provide
that abstraction coverage
to about 80% to 90%
of what you're doing.
There's always a certain amount
of leakage
with persistence APIs.
When you have to go beyond
the abstraction layer
and in
a relational database case,
you have
to start talking SQL.
Same thing is gonna happen
with BigTable.
Using the higher level APIs,
you can kind of forget
about BigTable's existence
80% or 90% of the time.
But a certain percentage
of the time,
you need to know you're talking
to a nested HashMap.
And you have to deal
with the way it allocates
its rows across servers
and clusters things together
and things of that kind
if you want
a decent performance.
And we all tend to want
enough performance
that we're gonna have
to do this.
This is gonna be a big shift
for a lot of enterprise
developers.
The relational database model
has had enterprise development
in a complete lock
for a long, long time.
And it's gonna be
a significant shift
to move over
to the nested HashMap model.
Parsons: We have high hopes
that it will happen.
Fowler: We do.
I mean, on the whole,
we quite like this.
I think this is actually
a good shift to go through.
And I'm not going to advise
Google to replace BigTable
with relational databases.
I don't think
that would at all
be necessarily a good idea.
But for you as users,
if you're thinking of developing
for App Engine,
you have to think about
that shift in persistence model.
And that's one very big reason
why you can't just port
a traditionally developed
Java app
and just say, "Oh,
we'll put it on App Engine."
Because you're gonna have to
change your persistence model
and that is not gonna be
a small adjustment
for most applications.
So that's
the persistence story.
The third topic to mention
is concurrency.
Now, JVM has had
a very particular model
about concurrency right
from the very beginning,
and that is that you have
one broad memory space
of objects that you're
dealing with in memory
and multiple threads operating
across that memory space.
And you have the power
to create new threads
within that memory space
anytime you like
and the responsibility
to arrange
all the locking and stuff
so that you don't shoot yourself
in the foot.
The Google App Engine
operates
on basically
a different model.
It says that we actually have
separate memory spaces,
each of which only has
a single thread operating in it.
And you can't just create
a new thread
within a memory space,
and certainly not
to let it access
the same objects.
If you want to communicate
between these memory spaces,
then you operate
with a database.
You operate with BigTable.
Now, there are lots
of pluses and minuses here.
The first thing
is that, notionally,
the Google App Engine model
of single threaded applications
communicating
through
a transactional database
is actually the way
a lot of people tend to think
about web apps normally.
A lot of people are wary
about shooting off threads
left, right, and center
because they know
it can shoot themselves
in the foot.
So they tend to use a thread
to handle
a particular web request
coming in.
Do everything all on at least
logically a single thread.
Storing stuff
off to a database
or some other kind
of session storage or whatever.
So the shift then, mentally,
in thinking
from the traditional
Java structure
to the Google App Engine
structure,
that's not actually
that big a shift.
Not at least
in the broad perspective.
But there are details
where there is an issue.
Now as I've mentioned,
one thing you can't do
in the Google world
is I've got a thread
operating on some data
and I want to spin up
a new thread.
Do that, you get an exception,
game over.
Well, that's fairly obvious.
I don't want to be doing that.
However, there are cases
when it's not so obvious.
I'm running some application,
I've got some thread
going around here.
I want to call some service
on an API,
some third party library
that's part of my application.
I don't really know very much
about this third party library
but it's gonna do
some useful work for me
so I call
a method on there.
And what I don't know is that
that third party library
has spun up a thread
without me knowing about it
and I end up getting exceptions
that I wouldn't expect.
And that is, unfortunately,
relatively common.
Because everybody's
used to the Java model
of concurrency,
people are fairly comfortable
with the idea of it
to be spinning up threads.
And if you've got some
third party library that's going
to do that, you're not
going to be able to use it
on App Engine.
This also particularly
hits people
if they're using some of those
alternative languages
I talked about earlier on.
A number of those languages
also do a lot of use of threads.
In fact, part
of the experimentation
is to make concurrency
more tractable,
and so they do this spinning
of the threads routine.
And as a result,
they're gonna have more problems
on the App Engine
because of that.
So on the whole,
the message to programmers there
is you've got to be wary about
what libraries you're using
and what technologies
you're using
to know about how they're
dealing with thread management
to know whether
you're going to be using them
with the Google App Engine.
But broadly,
the concurrency design
that App Engine leads you to--
these separate memory spaces
with a single thread
in each memory space--
is actually a model
that I would much like
to recommend to people.
I think it's a much more
tractable concurrency model
to work with that
kind of approach
than the shared memory, multiple
threads kind of approach
for the JVM encouraged.
Parsons: And again,
over time, I mean,
part of the power
of the Java platform
is the significant number
of third party libraries
that are available.
You've got libraries
to do practically anything.
Over time, as the Google
App Engine platform
becomes more popular,
many of those libraries
will be ported
in different ways,
taking into account
the fact that the thread model
is now different.
So this is a third message.
This is to the people
who are writing libraries,
is to start thinking
about this.
Are you actually--
Do you really need to be able
to fire up threads
or can you make
this functionality available
to people who are using Java
on the Google App Engine
in such a way that
we don't run up against
some of those
security exceptions?
So that's message number three
for this part.
Fowler: Yeah.
So that's three broad areas
that we've talked through.
None of these I would argue
are show stoppers.
And they're all things
that you've got to be wary of.
But certainly
the Google App Engine
certainly looks like
a reasonable platform.
I am not in the position yet
to say it's definitely workable
'cause I'd like to see
about half a dozen or so systems
in production before
I can say that kind of thing,
and it's still
too early for that.
But it certainly looks like
a reasonable platform
for a lot of cases to use.
And that's really the conclusion
from our experiments
and some of the thoughts
from that.
And so now I'll switch over
to Rebecca
to talk about the broader issue
of enterprise considerations.
Parsons: So we tend
to write larger apps.
And our experiments
kind of pushed on that as well.
We don't always write just
traditional web applications
and we do deal
with enterprises.
And although you can say,
"Well, there's hundreds
of thousands of millions
"of small business people.
Why do we have to worry
about enterprises?"
Well, there's still a lot
of enterprise development
going on out there.
And, in fact, what you'll find
in a lot of these enterprises
is there are
the early adopters.
There's a whole lot of people
out there
in that late majority
and who really are quite wary
of new technology like this.
So there are basically
three broad areas of concerns
that enterprises have with
something like App Engine.
I'm gonna start talking first
about some characteristics
of the App Engine
and in really the space
of different cloud offerings,
and how those different
cloud offerings might,
in fact, impact the way
an enterprise thinks
about experimenting in the cloud
or moving into the cloud.
Then I want to talk a little bit
about some of the paranoia
that exists in enterprises
to understand--why are
these people so afraid?
What's really wrong with this?
And try to talk through
some ways, then,
that we can start
looking at how enterprises
might get on an adoption path
to start using this
and overcome a little bit
of their paranoia.
So I want to start first
by talking about
the landscape, if you will,
of cloud offerings.
And I think it's important that
you think about this as a line.
And we've got some markers
in this line at the moment
which represent
current cloud implementations.
But there's a whole lot
of space in there,
and I think there's still
a lot of interesting areas
for innovation for people
to start exploring
the spaces
between those lines.
So in a very general way,
we have
our infrastructure clouds.
Pure bones bare
infrastructure.
Let's just have something
out there.
It places an awful lot
of responsibility
on the enterprise
to handle things
like system administration
and all of that.
But at least
you don't have a server
sitting in your data center
anymore.
So that's really
the most general infrastructure.
You've got an incredible amount
of power
but an incredible amount
of responsibility
within your organization.
Amazon is a good example
of that.
Next is the platform.
So I'm going to give you
something to play with
on this infrastructure.
I'm gonna give you
some restrictions.
You're still gonna have
a fair amount of power.
I mean, let's face it.
The JVM is still
a pretty powerful platform
to build on.
But I am building something
of a box around you.
I'm taking on
more responsibility
as a cloud provider.
You're giving up
some control to me.
So we've got kind of
a middle ground here.
Google App Engine
is a great example of this one.
And finally,
we have the very specific.
Salesforce.com is often
considered the standard here.
This is
a very specific application
that does a very narrow thing.
I have very little
responsibility
when I'm dealing
with Salesforce.
They're handling virtually
everything for me.
I've got some knobs to turn.
I've got a few things
I can fiddle with.
Yes, they have APIs,
but for the most part
they're worrying about
most everything.
However, although I'm sure
you could probably write
a text editor in Salesforce,
you probably wouldn't want to.
So I am giving up
some flexibility and some power
but that's the whole point.
This is an application-specific
cloud.
Now, in particular,
I think there's a whole lot
of interesting space
between the platform
and the application
where we might start
not having something quite
as specific as Salesforce,
but something that's
more targeted to a domain.
So we might start
looking at things
like
statistical analysis clouds,
where I still have something
of a programming environment
but I have a much narrower
domain focus
than something that's
general as the platform.
So I think there are a whole lot
of points in there
that are still
worthy of exploration
as we start to understand
how different kinds
of enterprises,
different kinds of applications
can make use
of the benefits of the cloud.
So what are those benefits?
Elasticity is the first one.
You really don't have
to think anymore about
some of the characteristics
of your application
that you used to have
to worry a whole lot about.
The cloud will flex
with your requirements,
and you don't have
to worry about it.
And that's important,
particularly when you want
to start thinking about
introducing something
into an environment
that's as dynamic as the web.
Who knows how popular
something's going to be.
You put it out.
Your server could crash
because you had no idea
that you were all of a sudden
gonna be slash dotted,
whereas in this environment,
that infrastructure
can flex to meet your needs.
To me this is one
of the most important.
Low barrier to entry.
One of the things
that used to happen
a long, long time ago
when I didn't have
so many gray hairs
is you had a lot of interaction
between the business user
and the I.T. people.
And someone
could sit down and say,
"This is the vision
of what I want to have happen,"
and the programmer was sitting
there and banging it out.
And now we have
huge I.T. departments,
and all of the separation
requirements documents
and all of this stuff.
What we need to do
is get business people
and development people
back together again.
One of the nice things
about the low barrier to entry
of the cloud
in Google App Engine
is now my business person
can come and sit down
and say, "I've got this idea."
And you can put it together
very quickly, very powerfully.
Put something out there.
It's elastic.
You can start
to get immediate feedback
from your customers on--
does this really work or not?
And if it's a good idea,
then you can start
to think about,
"So what else do I need to do
to really make this
enterprise ready?"
This low barrier to entry
should enable a lot
of innovation
in the businesses
where they can start trying out
some of their ideas
and throwing out
the nine out of ten
or 99 out of 100
that don't work.
Pay as you go.
To me, one of the most
devastating effects
of the last 15 years
on the I.T. department
is the fact that businesses
started thinking
of their I.T. departments
as cost centers.
And so they drove costs down,
and then all of a sudden
they say to their CIO,
"Why can't you innovate?"
And I can't innovate because
you made me
standardize everything
because it had to be cheap.
When you start working
in this kind of environment
with this pay as you go model,
you got a lot more flex
on your spend.
You don't have to invest
in a huge data center
if you don't need it
all the time.
One of our clients,
for example, they're a retailer.
Everyone knows when retailers
make all their money.
They spec'd all
of their data centers
so that they could lose
50% of their servers
and still handle peak load
with no more than 70%
utilization.
Just think of the waste
of all those servers
running the other 51 weeks
out of the year.
But that was what they
had to do to stay in business.
They had to pay all that
upfront.
License hardware
to handle peak season.
In the pay as you go model,
you use that--
you pay for only what
you need to use
when you need to use it.
This is also wonderful
as you're trying to get started.
And I think it also
is going to enable
a lot of this innovation
I was talking about
where you can start
experimenting with things
without having to invest
in a massive data center
to support something that you
might not actually want to do.
And economies of scale.
I don't anymore have to worry
about how much my data center
costs me
because I'm sharing all
of my costs with everybody else.
And we can have people who can
be experts at these things.
Let's face it, even a lot
of larger enterprises,
they don't have the wherewithal
to have someone
who's really an expert
in Oracle and in WebSphere
and in BizTalk
and in SharePoint
and on and on and on.
And all of these enterprises,
they have
to pick and choose where that
expertise is gonna come from.
You pool
all those things together,
and these cloud providers,
they do have the need
for those
specialized resources,
and we can start spreading
the cost of that
so I don't have to worry
about it myself.
And I don't have to make
those hard choices
of, "Okay, I'm not gonna have
an expert in this."
And when I get
into a world of hurt
then I'm gonna have to go,
hat in hand,
to one of my providers
and let them charge me
ridiculous rates
because I'm in trouble.
So those are
the kind of benefits.
And you can see those benefits,
and they go across
that entire space really
of different cloud offerings.
Some of them have
more of an effect,
say, on the more
application-specific one.
But in general,
these benefits accrue
regardless of where you are
in that continuum of clouds.
This is also how
I start to think about--
when is something
no longer a cloud?
If you don't have all
of these capabilities,
you're not really
in the cloud.
So that's really a framework
of thinking about
what the cloud is offering,
what are some possibilities
for when you might
really want to use it.
Now, let's talk about some
of these concerns for a minute.
As I said before,
there are a whole lot
of enterprises that are far more
on that late adoption part
of the curve.
They'll let
somebody else experiment.
We know several people
who would never dream
of installing
a piece of software
until it was
at least version 2.2.
And I've had some who say,
"Come talk to me when it's 5.
"All those other ones,
you know?
"They got to figure out
lots of stuff
before I'm gonna risk
my enterprise."
This is the standard one.
Security, privacy,
and intellectual property.
These are all variations
on a theme.
But the first thing
to realize
is how many times
when you hear on the news,
"Yes, somebody just got their
database compromised again."
You've got 2 million people
who now
have their credit cards
cancelled
and have to call everybody
because everybody
has all their bills going
to their credit cards now.
You don't hear them
talking about the fact
that that data center
was hosted by IBM or EDS.
You hear, "It's the institution
that lost the data."
So here you're asking
an enterprise,
with all of this value
in their market presence,
to turn over complete control
of something that valuable
to a different organization.
It doesn't matter who it is.
They're having to turn this over
to a different organization,
and that's a scary thought
for enterprises.
Yes, they aren't perfect
in protecting that, obviously,
but at least
they have control.
And if their reputation
gets trashed,
they can fire someone.
Yes, bye-bye, CIO.
It's your fault.
I've got my sacrificial lamb.
Now we can go back
and start to repair the damage.
Enterprises worry
about things like that.
And so they're gonna be hesitant
to turn over responsibility
for something like that
to someone that they don't have
a really big stick
to hold over.
That's why
a lot of those SLAs
that are in these
outsourced I.T. arrangements
are so stringent.
The enterprises at least feel
like they have a stick
even if, in effect,
they don't.
And then privacy.
How is my data
going to be protected?
How am I going
to ensure my customers
that other people
aren't looking at that data?
Or how am I
going to assure my CEO
that my competitor can't get
to my customer database?
So all kinds
of related items
around--
just how secure is my data?
I know if I've got it
locked away in my data center,
I've got it protected and
I know what's happening to it.
Now you're asking enterprise
to turn over
what is arguably one
of their most valuable assets
to somebody else
and let them take care of it.
Next one
I hear a fair amount is,
"Is it really cheaper?"
You see
all these wonderful slides
and okay, now we don't
have to pay for software
and we don't have to pay
for hardware.
Is it really cheaper?
From an enterprise perspective,
when you start
to think about this,
a lot of those other slides
rely on the fact
that pretty much everything's
going to the cloud.
All my email, all my document,
all my collaboration,
all my books, all of that stuff
is going to the cloud.
As soon as it's not all,
you're still left with servers
that you have to worry about.
You're still left
with ops people
that you still have to pay.
So how much of this stuff
really has to go to the cloud
before I start saving money?
A lot of that's gonna depend
on the shape of the enterprise,
how much--what
their other arrangements are.
But there's still
this nagging doubt.
"I keep hearing this stuff's
gonna save me money.
And it never does, so why
should I believe it here?"
I love this one.
"But I'm gonna have to
reorganize my I.T. department."
To which I say, "Good.
You probably need to."
But let's face it.
As soon as you start relying
on something like the cloud,
your needs internally are going
to change a great deal.
You might need
different kinds of people.
In fact, you probably will need
different kinds of people,
then that means
you're going to need
a different
I.T. organization.
This is not bad.
But some organizations just
like to reorg. just because.
Because it's fun.
They like to print
new word charts.
But these are
pretty disruptive activities
for an enterprise to take on.
And so even though it shouldn't
be that much of a problem,
enterprises worry
about things like this.
And, of course, at least
the enterprise architects
will have something new to do
because they'll have
to write a whole series
of new standards.
How do you use the cloud?
Which one of these features
can I really use?
When should I
really expose BigTable?
What are my standards?
Of course
you need new standards.
You're dealing
in a different platform.
This is not a barrier,
but it's just another thing
that an enterprise has to do.
And the ever-popular
vendor lock in.
If I go to Google App Engine,
well, then all of a sudden
now they've
jacked up the prices
by an order of magnitude,
and I'm locked
into my cloud vendor.
You're not locked
into a cloud vendor
any more than you're locked
into any other vendor
in your space,
and that hasn't stopped anybody
from buying Oracle
or anything else.
So yes, it does mean
that if you're on App Engine
and you decide
you want to leave App Engine,
you might have
to port something.
I don't see how that's
significantly different.
So the theme here is
yes, there are barriers
that a large enterprise
is gonna have to get over.
There's probably some things
in the security and I.T. space,
particularly in demonstrating
not just through
a legal document,
but generating through tests
or other activities
where you might actually say,
"Okay, I'm gonna go
to one of the hacker conferences
"and I'm going
to put a bounty on somebody
who can break
into this system."
So that I can start exploring
the vulnerabilities
of my system so these
enterprises can start to think,
"You know, if it's
that hard to break into,
"maybe it is all right
for them to start
keeping track of my data."
But in general,
a lot of these things
are just internal processes
and changes
that an enterprise
is going to have to absorb.
So those are the concerns.
So how do we recommend
enterprises start
to get over this?
And I do think that a lot of
them are going to start to try.
You're not gonna see them
putting
their huge enterprise internal
systems on there day one.
Not gonna happen.
But I do think there are
several paths
that they can take.
And the first one is what
I was talking about earlier.
With such a low barrier
to entry,
I'm sure in many
of these enterprises,
there are all kinds of people
with really great ideas
that just need the ability
to start to deploy.
And what's the common refrain
we hear?
"It takes so long for I.T.
to do anything."
Well, a forward-thinking CIO
would say,
"Well, let me
start to use this
and some of those ideas that
the CEO keeps tossing at me."
Start to experiment
with some of this
so I can get
quicker turnaround
and I can start to provide
value back to my enterprise
as well as I can start
to get comfortable
with this thing called
App Engine.
Big Ticket Single Shot.
One of the most--
more compelling stories I heard
at QCon last year
was the description
of a data migration.
Massive amount of data.
They would've had to buy
huge servers to make this work.
And they ran it in the cloud
and it cost them about $20.
Now, yes, that means
some of this very valuable
enterprise data has to be
on the cloud for a little while,
but you're not leaving it there
for very long.
I can maybe get behind that,
particularly if you tell me
I don't have to buy
a bunch of servers
or rent a bunch of servers
and set them up
and tear them down
and all of that kind of stuff.
So I think this is another one
where there's very high value,
single or nonrecurring
application rungs where again
you can start to demonstrate,
okay, this thing
really does work.
I'm starting to get
a rhythm within my enterprise
of making use of this new kind
of computational asset.
Focusing on what matters.
This is particularly important
for smaller organizations
and you hear it
in enterprise speak.
Focus on
your core competencies.
Why should an enterprise
that's trying to spin up
a completely new line
of business
have to worry about things
like data centers?
They don't worry
about plumbing.
about the cleaning help.
Some of these activities
are at that utility
or infrastructural level.
Let's not let my creative types
and my management bandwidth
go at managing something that
someone else can take care of.
Let me focus on things
that are important to me.
What's my differentiator
in the marketplace?
How am I going to address
my customers?
How can I have this better
relationship with my customer?
That's what enterprises
ought to be focusing on
rather than thinking about
things like a data center.
Fowler:
And this is also--
we see
a considerable intersection
between cloud computing
and agile software processes.
And we've been
very heavily involved
in agile software processes.
We've been doing them
since the very early days.
In the early days we'd kind
of have to do them in secret.
Now we're doing them
much more visibly.
And there's a number
of areas, I think,
where the cloud
can help us with this.
One particular area
is looking into how it affects
work in deploying
into production.
We are quite used to the fact
that we regularly deploy
applications into production
and roll them over
every couple of weeks or so.
Even a fairly big project
like the Guardian online,
we might have 40 or 50 people
in the development team,
but we're redeploying
into production
every couple of weeks or so,
or sometimes
even more frequently.
In that kind of situation,
deployment can be
a real pain in the neck.
For a cloud system,
this can actually make things
a lot more straightforward
because we have
the kind of infrastructure
that allows us to deploy
quickly into the cloud,
often not
with some of the hassles
that we might have from
some of the I.T. departments
we've known over the years.
Another very interesting
property of using the cloud here
is to enable testing.
I've commented about the fact
that testing
is actually a bit
of an issue at the moment
because of the difficulty
of getting that
local test server.
But one area where the cloud
can be really nice
is it doesn't cost us
very much to spin up
as many instances as we want
to be able to run tests.
And we find this
at the moment
with our Mingle project
collaboration tool.
It's written once
but then it has to deploy
on various different
operating systems--
the Mac, Linux, Windows,
various flavors of Windows.
It's got to work
on all of these browsers.
It's got to work on Firefox
and Safari and Chrome,
and it's got to work
on that big browser
that they damned mentioned
this morning,
that they
make up in Redmond.
And some old versions of that
can be a little bit tricky.
Now you just do the math
of the combinatorial explosion
of all of that and that's
a hell of a lot of servers
you need to run tests.
Perfect case for the cloud.
Spin them all up,
run the tests,
and you get rapid feedback.
And, of course,
rapid feedback is the key
to what you want
from this kind of testing.
Parsons: And, of course,
the businesses
who are always frustrated
with how slow
I.T. departments are--
well, this gives you
a much easier route
to work around.
Now, we've actually gotten
fairly adept at getting around
corporate I.T. departments
with some of the client
relationships that we've had.
But that's
a whole lot more difficult
for a marketing manager
and such.
And with something--with,
again, the low barrier to entry
that Google App Engine has,
now this person has
the ability to work around I.T.
in a way they
haven't had to before
or hadn't been able to before
because I.T. owns the passwords
and they own the servers
and they own the firewalls
and all of these things.
You've got a lot more power
that is being pushed
to the various business units
working in this model.
Fowler: And this is nary
a history course
teaching you
just something interesting.
All of those kinds of concerns
that were being talked about,
they might sound
kind of familiar
to those of you
with gray or little hair
in the way that we are
because we kind of heard
this argument before.
This is, I think, a point
that Tim Bray pointed out
really well on his blog.
This was exactly the arguments
against the use of PCs.
I.T. departments saying,
"Oh, we can't have PCs.
They're never gonna spread
for all these kinds of reasons."
Well, draw a lesson
from history.
Parsons: And the ever popular
quick and dirty,
but in this case,
quick and not so dirty.
You can actually
get some of these things up
fairly quickly
and still maintain a fair amount
of development rigor
and discipline.
So yes, I'm sure it's possible
to write something very messy
and awful and unmaintainable
in Google App Engine
just like you can in every
other development platform
known to man and even every one
that's probably
still to be written.
But you do have some pretty
powerful tools available
that will allow you
to put something up quickly
but not have to make
a lot of the compromises
that we often have to make.
And how much capacity
do I really need?
The number of times
I've been asked by clients,
"Well, can you tell me what
my data center capacity
needs to be?"
Well, can you give me
an accurate business forecast
for the next 18 months
on what all of your activity
at any given point in time
is going to look like?
No.
This same graph was the one
that was shown this morning
in the keynote.
This is the load
that was put onto the server
when Obama's
town hall was done.
Now think of what the poor
data center ops person
would have to do
to be able to have that peak
that's 1/2 an order
of magnitude greater
than where that normal line
is down at the bottom.
You're gonna have an awful lot
of very nervous people
running around,
and you probably had to have,
once again, built a data center
that could handle
that capacity.
That is if you actually thought
about it far enough in advance
to be able to provision it.
When you have no idea what your
profile's going to look like,
you have no way
to plan a data center.
You don't have to
in this model.
And it can be throttled--
so back to that poor retailer
who had to build
the huge data center
that sat idle
for most of the year.
You can run
at your base level
for the vast majority
of the time,
and it's only ratcheted up
when you need it.
Through quotas and other things
like that,
you could even
control this yourself
to make sure that resources
are being utilized properly.
So you have a lot finer control
over what your I.T. spend is
and so the CIO
can start focusing
on doing interesting things
rather than just
keeping costs down.
So those are the kinds of ways
that I can see
even some of the more
conservative enterprises
start to think
about using this, okay?
Well, let's let loose
my marketing department.
We need new market share
right now.
We need new ideas.
The expectations
from customers are tremendous.
So let's enable
some of these people
to start coming up
with some of these ideas
and deploy them in the cloud.
Or some of these
testing applications.
Let's make my application
more solid,
so again, my customers
won't be as unhappy.
These are the kinds of things
that enterprises
will start thinking about
and start to feel comfortable
using this strange thing
called the cloud.
Fowler: So that's
our prepared text as it were.
We have a little bit of time
left for questions.
So if you've got them,
please do,
but come up to the mic
so that the cameraman
can capture your questions
for posterity.
Okay, go ahead.
man: Hi, I have
a two part question.
First part is I know
you've been working a lot
on the main
specific languages, DSL.
And I would like to know
if it has a parallel
with what you're doing
with the Google Apps Engine.
And the second part
of my question
is just as Salesforce
has moved to the cloud,
will your P systems
move to the cloud as well,
either with Google Apps Engine
or some other system?
Do you see them moving
to the cloud?
Fowler: Two very different
questions.
You take the first.
Parsons: Yeah, so if you go back
to that infrastructure,
platform application
specific space,
I actually see DSLs
playing in that area
between the platform
and the application space
where you would start to see
those specific languages
being constructed
to enable a narrower range
of development to go on
on those specialized clouds.
So I see there's a lot of
potential in that space there
for people to start
putting up, again,
domain-specific application
platforms in the clouds,
leveraging things
like things like DSLs.
Fowler: And also,
I think, there's--
another interesting potential
synergy in the DSL space
is one of the
on the edge interesting things
in the main specific languages
is the classic tools
called Language Workbenches,
which are basically tools
that allow you to build
your own DSLs and editing
environments that go with them.
Those are actually
very well placed
to try and provide you
the abstractions
that will allow you to deploy
to a cloud environment
with a little bit more
hiding of what's going on.
And that could be
quite interesting
because of the fact
that you've got a new tool
and a new
deployment environment
that's shaking up the world
enough to where I think the two
could go
quite interestingly together.
On the second question,
will the ARP vendors
be moving to cloud?
I would expect so, certainly.
I mean, it's gonna be--
I can't imagine why
if you're going to build
and bring in an ARP vendor,
you're not gonna want
to just shift all of
the managing of the data center
over to a company
that specializes in it.
I mean, the historic route
is you get these specializations
of activity and I don't see
why running data centers
is any exception.
I would be very surprised
if in, say, 10, 20 years
we still see significant
data centers held by companies.
Because I think that
specialization could come.
Parsons: The greater
complication there
is so many enterprises
have customized
their S.A.P. or their
PeopleSoft implementations
to be very specific
to their business processes.
And the effort that it would
take to migrate those
into a cloud environment,
unless they still have
all the same kinds
of knobs to turn as they have
in a standalone ERP
implementation,
you're probably gonna see
a great deal of pain
in the migration process.
But I agree with Martin.
It is going to happen.
It's just a matter of time.
There are fewer knobs to turn
in things
like the CRM environment.
And I think that's why
the adoption into Salesforce
has been greater than you
might've expected otherwise.
If you think about it,
that's a pretty valuable
enterprise asset.
On the other hand,
the typical sales cycle
doesn't vary as much.
When you start looking at ERP,
it's gonna be
a more complicated problem.
man: Okay, thank you.
man: Hi, thanks for the talk.
I have two quick questions.
I'm relatively new to
the concept of a generic HashMap
becoming a kind of
a conceptual data store.
And so I'm interested--in
the relational database world,
they're really used
to being able
to index tables
in all kinds of different ways
and access data
in all kinds of different keys.
Does that mean that
in this type of data store
we would just have
to duplicate the data
and just use different hash key
for different access?
That's one question.
The second one is whether
you've had any luck
with JRuby on Rails
in the app store.
Fowler: So, you can still
link stuff together pretty well
using the notion of
the nested HashMaps because
as long as you can
get at the keys
and you know the path
through the nesting,
you can hook things together.
It is a different way
of thinking to relational.
There's not an easy way
to kind of sum up
the difference in thinking.
I'm afraid it's one of those
things that you have
to practice in order
to get used to.
Now the second question
I didn't quite catch.
man: It was whether
you had any luck
with JRuby on Rails
on App Engine.
Fowler: Well, Ola will talk
all about this tomorrow.
He's got a whole talk
on JRuby.
So we'll leave it to him.
man: Hi, I have a couple
of questions.
First is about you talked about
migration for a little bit
and you talked about the lock-in
of the Google App Engine
that exists
off any cloud platform.
Do you think the notion
that it's difficult--
it's more difficult to come out
of a platform than a database
like in Oracle
is because lots of people
have done, I mean, like,
a migration from Oracle
to some other database
but nobody has really tried out,
like, migrating an application
from Google App Engine
to some other framework?
And my second question
is regarding
the adoption section
of your talk.
You talked about a number
of compelling reasons.
Which one in your understanding
or experience
do you think will be
the most compelling
for the enterprises
to actually make the move
or start making the move?
Parsons: Okay,
so on the first one,
clearly migrations
that have been done before
are easier and I do think
there is some aspect to that,
just like with the libraries.
People haven't rewritten
the libraries yet
to deal with the different
concurrency model.
That will happen over time.
I think you will get more tools
to support these migrations.
This is a little more
complicated
because going from
relational to relational,
at least you're staying within
the same conceptual model.
You do in this world
have to think
about applications differently,
or you at least should
think about applications
differently.
So the migration will be more
complicated as time goes on.
I think we are gonna start
to see more and more tools
that are available
for these kinds of things
which will make it easier.
So a lot of these issues
that we're raising--
it's not a fundamental flaw
with the platform so much
as the tools
haven't caught up.
And we've been building tools
for Java for years,
for all of these other languages
for years,
and we're gonna do
the same thing here.
As for the adoption,
what I would like to say
is it's that ability
to innovate.
The flexibility of being able
to let loose
the creative people
within an organization
to start coming up
with new and better ways
of doing business internally
or interfacing with
our customers and such.
And I think that's
a very compelling reason
for a lot of enterprises.
They complain constantly
about how slow I.T. is,
how long it takes
to get anything done.
So I think that should be
a very compelling reason
for an enterprise.
I think they're going to be
focusing a fair amount on cost.
Fowler: Yeah, I think,
I mean, again,
drawing lessons
from history,
a lot of the people
who are getting into things
like PCs started
by effectively trying
to end-run around
I.T. departments
where you've got
some business people
and some technical people
who need to get something going
and get something operating
and don't want
to deal with the bureaucracy.
And I suspect
that's gonna drive it.
Because, let's face it,
by definition
it's gonna be the early
adopters that are getting
into Google App Engine
at the beginning.
And they typically do that
kind of end-running behavior.
And most of our clients,
they're not ready for playing
around with this stuff
broadly yet.
But you'll always find
most large companies
will have a few little
bubbles of people
that have got something
and are prepared to run with it.
And they will tend to do this
for innovation-driven reasons,
I think.
Parsons: Okay, and
we're getting close to time,
so if we can cut off
the line where it is.
man: Right, so my question
is more around
the enterprise adoption.
Sort of a follow on, I think,
large corporations
actually understand
and realize the benefits
of what cloud computing,
enterprise development,
and the cloud
can do for them in terms
of faster, better, cheaper.
And they're typically
mandated to those organizations
from CIO down
to the organization.
How do we innovate?
How do we be more faster
and do things cheaper?
And I agree with
most of the analysis
and the earlier private talk
about adoption
with exception
of the last part which was
really talking
about working around I.T.
And I guess my question back
to you is with all this pressure
from a financial perspective
and a need to innovate,
instead of
working around I.T.,
setting up the time
to actually figure out
how to capture
the hearts and minds of I.T
to actually
transform the company?
And I understand
the historical perspective,
but now, I mean, there's
so much pressure to change
and the tools
are so different.
So I guess it's just--
is it not the time to actually
capture their hearts and minds?
Parsons:
I actually think it is.
And I think we're gonna see
I.T. departments
that look very, very different
and that could be
a very long debate.
But I do think what
you're going to start to see
is a separation
of an I.T. department
into the very infrastructure
focused layers,
which should be cost driven.
And that area
of an organization
that needs to be more dynamic
and more responsive
and therefore closer
to the business.
And I think once you
start thinking about I.T.
and separating those things
rather than trying
to manage this heterogeneous
mass in the same way,
you can focus
on enabling the innovation
and enabling the rapid change
within your I.T. organization
which might end up then getting
dispersed a little bit more
while you can
focus the cost savings
on the things where it really
just is plumbing.
And so I think you're going
to start to see more of that.
And I do think there
is increasing pressure
on organizations to start
making those changes.
Last question.
man: Hi.
Not a question actually.
Just picking up on the fact
that there were
two questions related
to migrating applications built
on top of relational databases
to the App Engine data store.
I'm giving a talk
tomorrow at 1:15.
It's called
"The Softer Side of Schemas."
And this is--we've got
about 1/3 of the talk
devoted to strategies
for moving applications
on and off App Engine.
So if this is of interest
to you, please stop by.
Sorry to hijack.
Parsons: And which track
are you in?
man: The App Engine track.
Parsons: Okay, very good.
Thank you.
Thank you all
for your attention.
Fowler: Thank you.
[applause]